all right so i've said it before and
i'll say it again i am a big reactor
[Applause]
on the show look things happen and i
have big reactions okay because i care
about things and i'm passionate and
i
love life and i'm texans everything's
being huge so
today what we're going to be doing is
i'm going to be watching some of my like
big reactions on the show i'm sure
there's a plethora to choose from and
i'm going to try and guess what i was
reacting to which is actually really
hard
because i react to everything so this is
a game that we are calling wait for it
what is kelly reacting to
yeah
you're welcome
[Music]
all right so here we go this is reaction
one
oh somebody did a split
i grabbed i grabbed her
[Laughter]
i grabbed her so somebody must have done
this split oh was this person in the
audience and did they do like they ended
in like the splits and i feel like was
the person in drag no it was yes
how she
she
it was in a circle
her name is jada slade and that was
incredible and i got that one by the way
reaction number one check
yeah
what okay wait i gotta say that again
yeah
it's gotta be something to do with food
it's gotta be i'm gonna say that has to
do with food i'm not sure what
but i'm sure it's food i really am a
friend kelly because we have had them
delivered to you so there should be some
coming out to you right now
wait oh my god it looks so good i'm so
hungry my mouth is watering
i remember this
oh god how is it fair that trisha
earwood is cool as hell one of the
greatest singers on the planet and also
she is like the mom in encanto you know
that makes the her super power her magic
power is the food that heals you her
food is so good and it's just kind of
not fair because she's just out here
making us all look like clowns because
like we have like one talent and she has
like a lot of talents
i'm glad she's my friend
that was a good cupcake
i'm hungry
[Music]
oh i remember this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's amazing
so here's the thing
all there was was a bum bum bum bump
that's it i was like what
first one
everybody here knew it
right after i looked at my musical
director and was like play a song i'd go
and i should have really known that one
um yeah that was a little i was like i'm
dead i was like this is the saddest
like it was i was it was the worst game
ever played by me it's fine
we're gonna move on because i'm
obviously over it
that's not you though wait what oh is
this a colin is this colin
okay i knew it colin farrell i tell you
what
they showed him on that screen and i was
like i i was like wait what you play
penguin i play
yeah i play oz
um but it's known as the penguin they
hadn't shown it to us yet i wasn't able
to see it so i was like why are they
showing some other dude in some like
clip like why aren't they showing colin
farrell scene i was like what's
happening and i was kind of embarrassed
like for my tv crew i was like hey guys
maybe next time
let's put the person up that's like on
the couch a really extraordinary makeup
artist called mike marino kind of
designed the character i will say what
wait that's not you though yeah wait
what yeah
wait what
he looks like a different
human i can't kind of take too long four
hours
that's all i say about that
i can't even do regular makeup let alone
that
juicy
like
i didn't ever see the
he was like
was that the alligator
oh my god i'm amazing at this today last
time i was not good at this i don't
remember this this might be it i don't
know if it is though i don't know what
happened here what was that so happy
about
whatever he gets look at him
i mean what's smart
watch him watch him run um we have this
reptile
he's just like
leave the trash can i didn't care about
anyone he was like
[Applause]
wait oh i wish i didn't know what i was
gonna say um because i almost peed my
pants one time when i was on here
because i actually said something and it
sounded like i'd told sandra bullock
that like her parents is fine they were
dead i was like it was like how it was
worded was like what and and i freaked
out is that what that is my parents were
i was gonna say your parents i cannot
sing at all my parents were singing
about that um it's okay but they were
singers though okay but they're that's
cool wait you don't see that they're
dead or no they're singers that's so sad
that they're
sweating
i i love her so much and i was like
nervous like interview and she was
really cool but she's so funny y'all
y'all are not ready for how quick miss
bullock is thinking you said you don't
like doing furniture and stuff like that
[Laughter]
this is the best part
i move in and laugh and she moves back
she's like that's great she's so funny
no
tj or
do you decorate for christmas
[Laughter]
[Applause]
honestly god
like it's uncanny how close to like my
friends you are
the things that you've got with your
friends
as well
look i knew she was gonna be so cool but
like she's like she's maybe one of the
coolest people i've met in this industry
here's the final reaction
okay
i walked around i got tea in my
hands i don't know who that is
i don't know that one over the years
you've written so many amazing lyrics so
i want to ask you something
wait wait i know what this is before i
even see the rest of it this is whatever
i think it's learned to fly out or and i
was like oh that's so cool and i was
like his lyrics are like so deep like
all the ladies whatever he was like yeah
i was just looking at a bar and i
was like thinking yeah one of your most
popular songs is learn to fly i love it
um you wrote on it looking to the sky to
save me looking for a sign of life
looking for something to help me burn
out bright now this is once again it
comes back to that whole thing that i
love that you do for me whenever i'm
listening to your lyrics maybe you
didn't write it like this but it kind of
again to me is like a little dark and a
little light it's always there like a
shared world which i guess is life
i don't want to burst your bubble okay
i'm going to drink my tea
and you're like so this at the time i
wanted to become a pilot i would like i
wanted to learn to fly like i did
i mean like that's it like i was i was
like i was
i hate
but dave girl he was just being very
funny and he was like yeah no i just
thought it would be cool like learn to
fly and i went so
deep in it like artists like oh my god
so was your spirit like feeling and he
was like nah girl i'm sorry
i got like video tapes i was reading all
these books it really is i'm singing it
because i want to learn how to be a
puppy
every time we talk about a song i'd be
like yeah so i felt like this and i
connected to it he'd be like yeah
it was not that deep and every time was
i just gave up okay so everybody if you
like this let me know in the comments
what's been your favorite moment in the
show um so far this season and well you
might want to do that soon because like
there's only so much of the season left
so yeah i don't know maybe you hate my
reactions maybe you're like calm down
maybe okay so subscribe to my channel
because you know you want to because
it's just a good decision okay bye
[Music]
you